I was wondering if you would do kiss on
my list would you be good enough to
perform that for good you will do it
yeah all right Wendy's righteously
remember do you remember writing this
song sure you're sitting around and it
came to you quickly this song yeah did
one of those 10-minute jobs that was
interviewing Chris Martin from Coldplay
he said all of his hits came to him in
ten minutes some come that way
the kissimmee list came pretty fast yeah
I don't remember how long but fast this
is an oldie but a goodie as this yeah
okay here we go
oh yeah good luck boys
like 1 2 3
[Music]
do I call you all the time I can't say
me I don't feel the need to give some
secrets away
[Music]
maybe I need help
[Music]
No
[Music]
the smell
kisses on my list because you kiss your
kiss I can't resist
because it kisses
the best thing
because your kid
your kisses so my list
I can't
[Music]
what a turn
[Music]
the risk really see
[Music]
pick up your turn
[Music]
I'm doing
[Music]
[Music]
kiss your kisses on my lips
this is like a visa because you kisses
on my
[Music]
be honest
[ __ ] canvases
[Music]
because
because you kiss
because you kiss
[Music]
because you kissed
because you just your kisses on my list
tonight because your kids
[Music]
right
[Music]
beautiful boys are tight